i said to myself
some so you have two choices today
one you can either get raped
now
or you can just go with it
and so
that
it doesn't happen in a violent way
[Music]
i
remained a virgin because i was
absolutely terrified
of sex i was terrified of being
ripped so i thought how would it work
for someone who's who's had a procedure
like mine
do i
let him cut it do i
take myself to a hospital beforehand but
then you're ashamed for that as well
young girls who go to hospitals to try
to
open themselves up or have
reconstruction surgery are shamed
because like what's done is done now you
shouldn't want to change it just wait
for your husband
if a woman had experienced fgm and she
gets married
they either take scissors knife
something to open
that person up
um in some cases it is done in hospitals
and in other cases the man just
gets to open
um the present that he was given um
because it's shocked it's like it's like
a present you know it's it's not just a
wife it's
a
it's a gift you know you don't have
virginity her womanhood everything has
been kept for that one particular man
but when i was 17 years old i took a gap
year and i decided to go to somalia
and at the time
al-shabab were there not only did i
witness um al-shabab do horrendous
things
to people
but i also
met
my
family members
one of them being
my uncle
who came to pick me up from
the city that i lived in and took me to
his city that he lived in called marcade
omaka
and
as soon as i got there there were met
grown
men interested in marrying me and not
because of me but because of my british
passports it was you know all we would
want you to get married and
you know you're a grown woman now you
should consider it and i'm like i didn't
come here it's for a marriage
that's it's just
that's not what i came here for i came
to meet my family
to get to
um
to embrace my culture to
you know
get to know my land and my people but i
said marriage is not what i came here
for
and by this time i was very opinionated
but because al-shabab was there i had to
tone it down by
a thousand so i was not fully myself um
i remember i was in the shower
and i had him i heard a massive knock on
the door
and i'm like you know what's up
and my cousin said my female cousin was
like you know my uncle's calling you
this food is ready
and this was by far the best treatment
that i got since i got there
and they had all types of food
and a strange man
so
he was sat down with my uncle and i'm
not supposed to be in the same room
right as a strange man a man that i
don't know
so
my
uncle told me to sit down so i sat down
and he said this is the man that i want
you to get married to so i looked over
and i said no thank you
like i was ordering a pizza it's like no
thank you
and they started eating and
they started
telling me facts about
this person
so he's my auntie's son
and my mom's sister's son
and the second one was
um he's two years younger than me
so at the time i was 17
[Music]
and i think he was 15
and everything happened so fast i got
dressed up in this ugly
green dress with little sequences on it
my
uncle
gave us his bedroom you know the master
bedroom
so when you get married
you have to stay in that room for seven
days with your husband yeah the only
way you could leave that room is
if you're going to shower if you're
going to do wadu which is get ready for
a prayer that's that's it you can't
everything else you do in that room you
can't you know how to go outside you're
not allowed to go to the town or market
you're not allowed to speak to people
it's just you and that person i was put
in the room first um waited i think half
an hour to an hour
but
and this is i was 18 by then so when i
got married i had just turned 18.
and
i remember
him coming in
and the whole time i was in that room i
was thinking how are you going to escape
how are you going to leave
like
and all the things that can happen if i
try to escape
where i was sat there was a huge
cupboard um
with like a mirror and i was you know
reminiscing looking at myself in that
mirror
re-evaluating my whole life um
and then he comes in
stands dead like
the mirror that i was looking at because
i was daydreaming
so when did coming i didn't even notice
so he'd come in and he went past me
and he stood
right in front of me
and bear in mind i have never seen a
male genitals ever in my life
till that day and he's in somalia we
have mauis it's literally a
material that men wrap around their
waist
and he was wearing a shirt
and he just dropped it
because he just on just dropped it and i
i didn't know like have you ever seen
something so ridiculous that you don't
know whether to laugh or cry
like it
i was shocked i wasn't expecting it so i
didn't know whether to i genuinely
didn't know whether to laugh or cry
because
one is
it was very very very very unusual i did
i was in shock
and i didn't know what to do so i just
literally just stood still i did not
move from my position
and then again my 80 year old mind is
trying to get out of it so i said to him
can you help me take these pins out
because they've done this hairstyle that
requires so much
pins in your hand it was hurting
me so i asked him to come help
and but naked he did
and then whilst
he was helping again i was trying to
think of a way to get out
ah
i said to myself
some so you have two choices today
one you can either get raped
now
or you can just go with it
um so
that
it doesn't happen in a violent way
just just let it happen and then
tomorrow you can just tell him to you
know leave me alone you know don't touch
me
so i
let it happen
but
like i said i was a virgin
and i also
was
and when i say i was tearing
it was the smallest bit
and what he did is
as hard as i tried as much as i tried
i i couldn't
deal with the pain the pain was over
overwhelming it was crippling my whole
entire body
so i told him to stop
i tried to
get him off me
it didn't work
so
my first experience of
sex was unfortunately through
um
[Music]
rape
and
i remember the seven days that i was in
there
after the first day
i felt so numb
and so scared and even more scared than
i was before because i thought okay like
these people would go through any length
any length to get what they want
and even though i'm a strong person and
i although i
you know express how i'm feeling and i
fight for what is right i couldn't do
any of that there i couldn't
i was
honestly forced into silence after the
first day
this woman came to visit me to check
whether
we had had sex or not
and all i could say was yeah
that's it she's like well done you know
you've made your husband really happy
day two
i was raped day three of my honeymoon i
was raised four
and then the fourth day
i don't know what he did
um to my insides but
he caused so much damage that i could
not
um
urinate
i couldn't before it wasn't easy before
like whenever i would go to the toilet
the smallest amount would come out and
the rest i could feel would shoot back
up
and
i would lay down on the floor because i
couldn't i could fizz i could not my
body couldn't handle it
none of them wanted to take me to a
hospital
nobody paid for um for any type of
treatment i didn't get any treatments i
i lived with my
internal trauma
or internal damage i lived with it on
the fourth day
because of the damage that had been done
to me
internal and external
i told him if you touch me
like
we're going to have issues
don't touch don't touch me
don't touch me
i think for the first time i spoke up
for myself and he kind of got
scared a little not scared
but he's like you know
shocked him a little bit
um
and
for the remaining three days he didn't
touch me
however after the seven days was
finished
um
after the seven days was finished i was
kicked out of my uncle's house he
himself kicked me out because he did
what he wanted to do which was marry me
off to somebody
and then chuck me
like i was
like of no worth to him anymore as soon
as we moved out he
what the one what was considered i
consider him my rapist
others would consider him my a husband
he would go back to my uncle whenever i
refused to have sex or to cook or to
clean
and the advice that my uncle had was
take everything you want by force
and if she refuses hit her
so
apart from those three days
that i
used my voice in order to leave to get
him to leave me alone
those were the three days that i had a
break
after that it was continuous
never ending cycle
of
the sexual assaults
throughout our marriage
it was i think eight to nine months
and
i was
raped continuously i was beaten i was
shoved
the fourth time
he beat me
was what i considered the worst
because not only was i on my period
but i believe i had a really bad
infection
from
the regular sexual assaults
and the previous um
damage that was done during the
honeymoon
it all kind of added up and that day i
was
i really wasn't myself
so when i woke up
he just
i i didn't know what it was i just felt
weight on me and because we
didn't have an argument prior i wasn't
waiting i wasn't expecting it
and it kind of happened out of the blue
so he
was on top of me and he was he started
punching
like my head
my face
my chest
my stomach
and just worked his way down
he
picked a day
where i was unable to move
a day where i could not defend myself a
day where i was so weak that i couldn't
even lift the finger
um and before he did any of that he hid
everything in my kitchen
knives plates like anything that i could
use against him or to hurt him he hid
but because i had such a fear of these
terrorists that were living in the
country at the time i thought i can't
even kill this man i can't harm this man
in any way because if i do
i'll die
i can't escape i can't defend myself
because if i do i'll end up in prison so
i'm like what what am i supposed to do
i remember when he was done
he left the room so fast
and i barricaded myself
into
my room
i would rather die
than
continue to live like this
and
i
there were two couples living in the
same house in a different room
so i called out to them
and
took
their phone and i called my mom
and the first thing i said is
is this what you wanted for me
and she's like what are you talking
about
and i said is this what you wanted for
me for me to be beaten forced into a
marriage
my mom didn't know about the forced
marriage she didn't know
what i was being subjected to
they actually tried to tend her against
me
and she goes to me okay if this is
what's happening she goes we need to get
you out of there
and she told me
you're sick right because i told her
that i'm ill but i haven't had um any
medical treatment
so she said make it like go to your
husband
make it seem like everything is fine
right even have sex with him if you have
to
right make it seem like everything is
good you are in a good place with him
you've forgiven him for everything so
that he doesn't suspect that you're
leaving
right
i
wore a
big hijab like
from head to toe
huge
and i wore a nikab or a burka they call
it
um i wore gloves i wore socks
i was
totally covered up from head to toe
and from checkpoint to checkpoint to
checkpoint to checkpoint
it was nothing
it was you know inspecting the driver
they didn't ask any of the females to
take off their clothing or the garments
so
i was like okay
and then but i knew until i got to the
border um controlled by the government
that i was still not safe
so i didn't say a word to anybody on the
bus um because i knew that they would
notice that my somali is completely
different from theirs
no then they could see that i'm not from
here or i'm new
to back to the country
so i kept my mouth shut and i just
constantly prayed prayed prayed pray
prayed prayed and i think that's why
they left me alone because i might have
been doing it loud i got to murder and
my two aunties were waiting for me there
these were
women women were standing up for me
my aunties whilst my uncles were the
ones that were putting me down
finally we came back to london in
2012.
i found out because my brother came to
get me
i found out that
my mother whilst i was going through all
of that
when
she was suffering from
a brain tumor
and
it was
stage four
and it was
it was aggressive
and
i came on the 1st
my mom died on the 7th
of february
exactly seven days
of me being in the country
and
out of all my experiences
i think this upsets me
the most this is the one that
makes me
emotional
because this is someone
that saved my life this is someone
that i love that i grew up with that i
treasured
and
she was the only person that i wanted to
talk to about everything that happened
and she was taken
like that
so how are you now
um
i'm good
i haven't
fully
healed
because i
haven't had therapy
it's something that i am
[Music]
actively looking to receive now
but
i have a beautiful baby girl that has
completely changed
my
me
she's she's really changed me and
she brought hope and love into my life
having a daughter
made me realize that now i need to
do my part
in
healing
myself
working to help me
um
whilst also
ensuring that i don't hand down
generational trauma to my child
so
i
can't even tell you how far i have come
i had such a negative negative outlook
on life
i
had trust issues
i had abandonment issues
i was a people pleaser i wanted to
please everyone i wanted to feel
accepted to feel loved
but i never got any of those and when
my daughter came it was
my life was filled with so much love and
laughter after my mother passed away i
could not
mentally handle
my community i could not handle my
family
so i moved to a town where no one knew
who i was
[Music]
it was myself and my daughter i did not
know anybody
in that town
and i started
a new life
from scratch
just like my mom told me and
honestly that is the best thing that i
have ever done for my mental health is
to move away from that toxic
energy and the people who were
you know responsible for the way that i
was feeling
and the family that was supposed to
protect me
who completely abandoned me at the time
that i needed them and rather blamed me
i also started learning about my
religion
islam
and a lot of the things like fgm forced
marriage marital rape being beaten
were all told to me that it was accepted
in islam which is completely unutter
anybody that tells you that marital rape
is okay is lying it is not acceptable in
islam in any way shape or form
it's a cultural thing they think that
it's acceptable in culture because
they're so used to
um
violating women they're so used to
violence against women that they think
you know she's this she's just another
property
i feel really sad for
the people that the young women that
don't have a voice
the ones that feel trapped
the ones that are afraid of shame
the ones that are afraid of being shamed
for
them being sexually assaulted for them
being domestically abused for
um
them being
attacked
is not okay to shame and it's definitely
not okay to silence a woman
you have
if you have a voice
use it
he looked young he did look young but it
was after the marriage that i knew that
he was twice my age so i was 15 he was
30. i knew i knew he was going to rape
me and that's what happened and it
became like every single day